she said i was just interested in a body
and i told her honestly your body was
the first reason that i liked you and
she got even madder at that
obviously
[Music]
ladies and gentle ladies
you're tuned in to your boys
jimmy mula
and fire bending for eggs oh my god
fire lord for eggs
[ __ ] it up
so um
guys welcome back
you know what to do
just for a second but okay all right do
me a favor guys right everyone listen to
sharp for a second everyone shut up
shut up everyone's sharp
pause the vid right now right
actually wait to finish the sentence
then pause it
everyone shut up then pause the video it
makes no sense all right everyone shut
up for a second
let me finish the sentence then pause it
right
pause it in a few seconds
and then scoring on over to patreon.com
forward slash [ __ ] i can never say it
foreign
shits and gigs yeah yeah patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs every
thursday
young peeps every thursday you're
missing out 50 of the apps if you're not
over there
they're popping off they are they're
popping off we just did we just did a
would you rather pick your poison
marathon and it went off
it went off over there last week flying
off the shelves well come on man
so jump in um
okay you can unpause it now
oh wait pause again
go over to
um wait pause the video
yeah positive
your chat is aware for thinking
go get some merch brand new merch summer
edition it's looking
chef's kiss yeah
affluent yeah yeah affluent it's buff so
then ones are flying off the shelf as
well um so thank you guys for the
support on that we're loving the summer
dish um fuja got chirps in mcdonald's
yesterday by a 98 year old man um who
was feeding the match feeling it he was
like is that you is that you pointed to
the merch is that you he's like yes me
yeah who's that the other guy
was that
it is
him
gast i don't blame him hilarious man
that was hilarious that was funny but
anyway guys unpause the vid
and we're ready to jump in now we're
ready um so without further ado
it's the fifth of her the
today guys my fun fact of the day
is
there's a guy called um what's his name
sorry
albert spaghieri it sounds italian but
he's french so i may be mispronouncing
it wrong so please forgive me but anyway
a guy called
albert spaghieri
he was a french gangster he was arrested
after his gang stole 60 million frank's
worth of valuables from a bank
at his trial he distracted the judge
then leaped out of the window and fled
on a motorcycle specially set up for him
he was never caught and died a free man
i'ma give you more context on them what
year was that
19
it was early i think 1980s or like 1970s
because he died in 1989. so it was timer
he said frank's they they might be still
using hearts yeah yeah french fox back
then so it was it was a decade ago
so basically
um during his case hearings
spaghetti devised an escape plan he made
a fictitious document which he claimed
as evidence he made the document coded
so it had to be deciphered by the judge
while the judge richard boise that's his
name was distracted by the document
spaghieri jumped out of the window
landing safely on a parked car and
escaped on a waiting motorcycle
some reports said some reports said that
the owner of the car later received five
thousand franc check in the mail for the
damage on the roof
left wing papers later said that
spaghieri had received help from his
political threat police why did i say
like that from his political from his
political from his political friends
in particular from an
x-o-a-s militant close to the mayors of
nice jacquise medicine i don't even know
i'd say his name i don't know i said
about that ever
the accusations forced by medicine to go
through and sound a second round of
voting at the local elections in 1977 so
it was around that time it was around
like the 1970s mid-1970s
um in 1995 there's another guy called
the jacques
accused christian estori i thought why
am i talking like that you got a jesus
christ
french prime minister and the former
motorcyclist champion of having been
spagheri's driver but estori
proved that he was in a race at the time
so yeah basically what that bit was
saying he was accused of being the
the driver of the time at the um the
getaway driver getaway driver he's a
race car driver yeah but he's a rape but
he proved that he was at a race at the
time of the escape but yeah
boys
supposedly yeah the frenchman is there
yeah and but he is um he was sentenced
to
in absentia to life imprisonment so that
means
when you're sentenced to a life in
prison but you're not physically there
so they've sentenced him but he couldn't
find him but he still died a free man
what a point this is stupid i don't even
know if that still exists but that's
what the terminology is but yeah and
i'll show you a picture of him now
he does look like a [ __ ] french
gangster to be fair
he does he looks like a french gangster
so hang on
excuse me
let me just take a picture of my head so
i understand what's going on here
so him and his boys robbed a bank for 60
million
60 million frags no
they robbed [ __ ] worth 56 million worth
16. all right cool so went to a bank him
and his gang robbed 60 million frank's
worth of [ __ ] yeah he gets caught
his gang is out here but he gets caught
then he makes a document
and gives it to the judge and says read
this this is evidence this is evidence
yeah and judges i swear and that's the
judge is like the [ __ ] is this try to
decipher it like something
somewhere's wally thing and i said what
is this and he's like you have to decode
it yeah if you want me you have to
decode the thing
and then he's like are you waist man
those are the things that you're lucky i
love puzzles
versus little speakers
yes yes
you're lucky you're lucky i love puzzles
why is nigeria
you're lucky i love puzzles
[Music]
i said why is that jerry and i don't
know
that's hilarious i'm unfolding rats
around there
oh lucky i like puzzles
just edge up
just deciphering just a separate thing
mine just
just dazzles the security guard
twisty's ain't cool spin move jumps out
the car jumps out thing lands on a car
and hops on a random bike
supposed to be planned
so cliche fam so cliche
it sounds like a plot of um
money heist like i said
are you up to date on that do you watch
that
nah
i know i i literally
watched
seventy percent of the first episode and
i was just like it wasn't bad
but it was just like
i just at that time i just didn't have
it in me if you had were you watching
other things that were like better if
you could remember i can't remember bro
bro la casa de papel is [ __ ]
incredible i believe it i don't i do i
don't know i just feel like i've seen so
many flipping
things like that name three
prison break
fair play
that even come to my head right so
prison break
oceans 11 12 and 13.
okay okay fair enough um what else have
we got inside man
that's a movie i saw that again i think
jordan locked down i saw that again yeah
man um
what other ones are there that's like
intricate like planning things like that
um
they've got that new thing that i watch
a little bit of that loop on
i've never seen that but i've heard good
job i was like a couple episodes it was
all right i've heard um
so yeah man i've seen like a lot of bank
[ __ ] fair enough i said name three names
also i i need to shut them up about that
but
the reason why i feel like it's great
one because it's a series yes i know
prison break is a series um but prison
break was like a decade and a half ago
it was a long time ago and
i feel like because
because um it's more a lot more modern
the way everything just set out and the
way the episodes are set out it's
everything is just a cliffhanger and
every
obviously every character has such a
great story and obviously you don't know
their names you don't know anything and
it's just
and again because in another language i
don't know why i like watching things in
other languages yeah and because it
makes me realize like it makes me
appreciate that
english
written and or directed or english
spoken shows or series or tv or movies
rather aren't always the best yeah
they're not the [ __ ] they aren't always
the best
foreign movies or foreign series
sometimes they just said bang they're
just creme de la creme bro and that is
one of them it's what a promise of
really i'll i'll give it another chance
it's a really good show we'll jump back
on five jobs drops in
september i think first week of
september
if i'm not mistaken if i'm not mistaken
i think ozark do you watch ozark i love
ozone thank the lord thank the lord yeah
ozark i think season i think it's season
four or season five for cardboard which
one they're on jobs in september as well
really yes
it's
amazing amazing it is amazing jason
bateman's a genius he is a genius bro
he's an actor he's a writer actor as
well bro done bits bro he's done bits
ah i would have ozark's one of the few
shows i would have you start again oh
hundred percent i love watching someone
that's not watched it before so i could
be fully engulfed in it again you know
ozark is [ __ ] amazing it's incredible
man i love that show
bro in season one where donnie um his
misses getting banged by that guy and
the guy gets dashed out the window bro
splatters on the floor bro
in just like the middle of the street um
when he says it about her something like
that i can't remember what he says where
he said something says something on the
line's like the most satisfying thing or
the the most happiest i felt was
watching like your lover's
body parts like smack all over the
sidewalk
i that's tough i hate his wife
i enjoy hating his wife
she annoys me but she came into her own
in season three like the most recently
that's the thing she did
she did that's how do i explain it
right
it's one of them ones where it's like
she did come into her own
and all that which is great
but it's like
how do i explain this
how do i explain it
i don't know it's just like so in a
nutshell it's just like my man
has been doing this for years
and it only [ __ ] up because his
partner was a greedy [ __ ]
and his wife didn't know about it the
kids didn't know about it no one knew
about it and he's got millions in the
bank
he's been doing this for years and he's
been
locked down tight yeah and he's like
this is a proven method of how this
works yeah and it's only [ __ ] up
because another [ __ ] [ __ ] it up i was
fine yeah i just want to get back to
that
um and she's like cool whatever blames
him for a million things et cetera et
cetera
he tries to sell her a big man
let's not forget you were a chee
let's not forget that let's not forget
that she chucks it out in the first
couple seasons she touched any chance
she can get yeah yeah let's not forget
you're a cheating [ __ ] let's just not
forget that
and you'll exit me because your lover
got killed yeah
it's your business that's really not my
problem it's really not it's not
um but nevertheless he's trying to run
his ting
and then my girl just gets aspirations
from
it just starts working behind my man's
back because she's greedy too yeah yeah
because she's greedy too and he's like
all these greedy [ __ ] are ruining my
life
look i hear what you're saying but i
enjoyed watching her character
development oh i enjoyed it that's what
i said i enjoyed hating her um
and um
when she had to um
when she had to drop her brother off at
the restaurant
bro
i could have cried bro
i forgot about that that's the most
recent season i forgot about he's an
actor as well he's an actor
bro he did well um
yeah i don't want to spoil the show guys
but if you've never seen ozark watch the
trailer on netflix but i promise you
it's three seasons maybe four seasons
deep now
but you would love it top three best
shows i've ever seen top three easy it's
incredible
unbelievable for me ozarks like on game
of thrones level
i don't know about that well then again
i think it's hard for me to compare the
two
purely because game of thrones has eight
seasons and ozark only has three maybe
four going into four
um
i think they're both equally as great
but then again
there are some seasons and maybe like
some
episodes in a season of game of thrones
where
not necessarily could have done with
that but it's clear they just tried to
stretch it yeah you know yeah yeah so i
understand where you're coming from
because with ozark is back to back
bangers right
doesn't miss every episode is a banger
but nevertheless there are some episodes
and game of thrones for me
for me
that are just
top three episodes i've seen period i
agree period i agree fam the battle of
the bastards that's exactly what i was
going to say battle of the bastards when
jon snow saw every man running towards
him and he was like [ __ ] and he grabbed
his knife i said he big man i saw and he
was like what am i gonna do you just
took a deep breath
and all these boys came
all these boys
when my man was stuck in the middle
who's trying to hitchhike quicksand
quick a human pile of quicksand that's
the most like realistic
rendition of like what actual war in
them days would have been like oh
squish up the in there man i was
thinking now oh i was like
i'll panicking after that i'll be
screaming bro we think what i've done
that episode and there was an episode i
can't remember what season it was but
there was an episode where it was just a
fight it was in
i want to say king's landing
where's the spot where
all them ah what's this place called
uh i want to say it's king's landing but
i could be terribly wrong they were
fighting
i think they were fighting the white
walkers maybe they just intruded but it
wasn't like season eight it was like
season four or five
really
it was with
uh i think it could have been the
episode where john snow got stabbed at
the end i think that was like season
four season five it was the end of the
season
and then he got revived again in the in
the
um
opening up like season five
what is that place called man
oh what the wall
he got killed at the wall yeah yeah yeah
so in that what's that thing called it
was where they were at they were all at
that's the um what's that's called the
wall in it it's called um
that's annoying me it's called the um
oh you're gonna go to the where they
send everyone yeah yeah uh it's called
um
i know they call it the wall but what
was it actually called i remember that
episode where from beginning to end it
was just a war
yeah i remember it was just a war and
when they did um season eight episode
three when arya killed um the knight the
night king it reminded me of that yeah
again that episode was just fight
and i was just like wow there are some
episodes in game of thrones that are
amazing
and like how are you even doing these
kind of things bro how are you even
directing that it's incredible is it
good it's incredible oh my goodness you
know i just remembered as well what the
red wedding oh it's called the um sorry
it's called the the nice watch
the night's watch the night's watch
people were screaming people screamed
the night man said king's landing
i knew it wasn't cool that was a nice
watch yeah you know
but yeah the red wedding do you remember
that yes oh my days they dope all of
them i remember that bro oh that's not
oh yeah some episodes you found there's
different episodes some episodes
when um
what's his name uh tyrion
seeing that his dad was banging his
misses
and just kaka his dad in the toilet
nah episode
episode that's like anyone can gain fam
in the episode where um
jon snow and dead man they've gone
past the wall
and they bump into the white walkers and
they're they're satin on like a pit of
ice and they're there for like a day fam
they're there for like a day because
they can't move they can't move
they can't move where to go and then
daenerys comes with the dragon just
marks off everyone
and then the the the night king just
bang one dragon mine now
bread's real that dragon's mine now and
it just boom and they just dragged it
they dragged it out and then before the
eye opened and that was the end of the
episode family
family april is the next family give
present next time so this is why i say i
don't think i can compare the two i
don't think i personally i could say
they're on the same level personally i
feel like when i say i compare the two
for me it's like um
just the excitement i get when i'm
watching it i understand and just like
if anyone's near me it's like shut up
i'm trying to pay attention yeah no one
speaks i understand that episode where
she dropped on you off at the restaurant
i don't think i breathed for the whole
thing
fam
and she was as soon as she was peeling
off she was weeping i could have quiet
weeping i could have no clue i could
have cried i literally could acquire an
episode my man just came through with a
silencer
i promise you fed i was this close to
tears i felt that bro
to my own brother nah i couldn't i
couldn't do it for the cause bro and she
pulled up on the side of the road she
made it like 10 minutes down already had
to pull up
on the phone
ballin
he was a great addition to the show
because
i think without him in that season this
is we're back to ozark by the way and
when i talk about game of thrones um
there wouldn't have been as much uh
controversy like oh yeah what kind of
controversy controversy um there would
have been that much so
his edition was
perfect bro absolutely he was just
[ __ ] stuff up
he was just [ __ ] stuff up bro
when he walked up to the boat party
i was just thinking when he walked up to
the boat party trying to get his mrs
back and stuff mouthing off
[ __ ] everything up he's like yeah you
have to go
no wonder you have to go you bipolar son
of a [ __ ]
no wonder you need to get buried my girl
oh yeah my guys ozark you've never seen
it
tune in big man in it's a it's a great
show trying to think of whatever points
had me like
crazy with it
i'm trying ah my camera
i remember more of season three season
one or two hey command the biggest bit
of the whole show what the finale of
season three i can't remember when um
nah i think it was might be finally
season two okay when um
obviously
um my man's pattern what is doesn't make
paper's name in it i can't remember
i would kept on thinking about it whilst
we're talking about it but i can't
remember anyway
when jason bateman finally patterned the
relationship between the mob boss
and the hero the poppy field guys
and he brought them together and they
were finally about to patent something
marty marty bird marty yeah we might
put everyone together and he's finally
patted it and he's like gang you guys
are going to do this we're going to
build a casino in the yard fam and he
called the mrs satin crazy or something
like that and she was like yeah bang
why older
i forgot about that i forgot about that
jaw dropping episode
anyone can get it anyone could get an
ozark
sharp
this fridge annoys me sometimes but bro
anyone can get it oh man great shot
anyone could get it that ruined
everything marty tries so hard to keep
his [ __ ] together i don't know how he
must have a stomach ulcer he must have
sat in bro
he drinks pepto-bismol by the gallows ah
bro i'm so stressed all the time always
i couldn't do what he does i would have
given up in like episode one season one
hundred percent because it's too much
for me i'm not built like that you know
especially with a family and hiding it
from the family handle it i'm not built
like that bro couldn't handle it and
then he's just got the on top of that
you've got the feds on him all the time
all day every day always sniffing around
rocking up at the casino whenever they
want sitting in his office
checking through all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
genius he is a genius genius ah and
every time something he patterns
something perfect and he gets [ __ ] up
by someone else i don't know how it
doesn't break down and be like you man
are killing me with this he sees the
bigger picture all the time all the time
bro the bigger picture all the [ __ ]
that's a spider bro i'm telling you from
this spider's about it
what's going on the spiders out here
i'm sick of it if you had
i'm utterly sick of it
granted they're outside but jesus christ
spiders
oh god
i think it's i think it's your city fam
we've seen spiders today
today just today we've seen spiders
everywhere um but yeah i was like gamer
friends both are okay unbelievable bro
unbelievable i believe i love both of
them man oh wow i think when it gets to
a point of
proper relaxation in terms of like this
is our full-time job and all of that
stuff i'm not working anywhere else and
i've got free time
i'm gonna binge game of thrones again
i'm gonna because right now i don't
think i've got the i would love to do it
but i'd want to watch it like back to
back to back so i can deepen appreciate
a lot yeah yeah yeah yeah
every week and i'm waiting a year bro
yeah it's true yeah you know fam gaming
friends will be fair
up at four gameplay the morning to watch
the american one yes yes because they
didn't want spoilers throughout the day
you couldn't be on social media
you couldn't used to go to work and
literally wouldn't touch anything social
media bro there were times that was one
of the big the main saving graces of me
working in hospitality especially if i
did later shifts i would be able to
catch the i think i was at 2am oh yeah
yeah i might be able to catch the
american life yeah i wasn't watching
that i wasn't sleeping i'm going to have
to wait until eight the next day
bro
you just know every time
the episode ends you just know [ __ ] next
week's gonna pop next week's gonna pop
bro
battle of the bus is probably one of my
favorite episodes period of anything
ever period yeah it was unbelievable i
can't believe what i saw
that and obviously i can't remember the
episode i know it's season eight episode
three like the main fight with the night
king oh yeah blah blah blah coming with
the episodes called that as well [ __ ]
incredible
[ __ ] incredible sick still um
oh wow bro
there's one there's crazy episodes in
there when um
when donnie made
my man reek
when he captured my man theon mm-hmm
what a loser
he got captured so many times theon
great choice what a loser top loser he
would side with anyone to stay alive
yeah
man would remember when mom stinks in
his own sister didn't know yes she just
firmed it as well oh my goodness
theon poor you
when he got captured
tall lop off
man said your name's reek
you're my little reek
he bullied him
he bullied him
bullied him oh my god when um
i can't remember his name you know do
you ever did you ever watch misfits yes
so you know who i'm talking about yes i
can remember his name in game of thrones
yeah i think he got jumped in like
season five or something
and
when they first introduced him with the
dogs that he's got in his cage and stuff
and he was such a was thought he was a
villain bro top-notch video there's a
villain in that show
i was like wow it shows that because
i've i think i've only ever seen him in
misfits prior to yeah yeah yeah same and
i'm thinking wow you can act bro bro you
can they introduced him well as a
villain he was a villain i need to
remember his name just for context but
yeah what in um in game of thrones it
was um
he was a snow as well wasn't he a cup
bro i honestly can't remember he didn't
because he didn't have his dad's name
yes i remember that
uh his real name is
you and rhion
yeah he didn't have his dad's name and
then i think he finally got given his
dad's name can't remember
[ __ ] he was a
he's a serious guy absolute villain
game of thrones his name is
ramsey bolton big man ramsay bolton
ramsey bolton yeah yeah top-notch
villain one of the best villains in the
whole show maybe the best villain in the
hospital bro i can't believe
he's a better to me he's a better
villain than cersei
oh yeah because
cersei yes was a villain but she was a
villain from season one season eight
yeah whereas he had to
he had to
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it bro
he came in mid-story when everyone else
had their own [ __ ] exactly and was like
left a footprint in there exactly
because i think
the first episode of that season he was
introduced it's not like he was
introduced missy first episode he was
introduced and you're like [ __ ] what's
he doing there like who is he blah blah
and from the jump you already knew he
was a friend man said you're my little
reek bro
pissed on him lopped his dick off
everything bruv villain made him a slave
villain bro i loved it yeah and his dogs
bro oh he would lock anyone to them dogs
it's wild i love the way he died
obviously for people that have not
watched it i'm not going to say it but
oh yeah yeah it's a good twist
i love the way he died yeah man [ __ ] me
all right tv shows we can talk about tv
shows we could go tv shows forever that
was that was just too just too juicy
it's too juicy um this is rand all right
i've got a rant actually
cool
i've got a wood driver then i've got a
random thing to say
so would you rather right
i have to say it
i don't really want to say it it got
sent into us ages ago and i was like you
more than anyone would understand this
one
okay and i have to so i have to say it
but it's just like
i'm happy to discuss it but i don't
really want to talk about too much but i
just need to get it out there okay would
you rather
be in two girls one cup
oh my god
or one man one jar
oh my god
those are villainous
villainous videos
i remember watching them like i think i
was in secondary school when they
dropped
i watched
two guys one cup when i was in secondary
school
and i think you showed me one man one
jar did i yeah i think so i don't remem
you showed me one man one horse as well
i think did i fam i don't remember these
you don't remember one man one horse
obviously i know the context of but i
don't remember showing you that's all
right i don't remember showing why are
you man dead i don't remember changed my
life one man one day i'm certain you
showed me i changed my life
one man one job i'm certain you showed
me
is that when he's sticking up his baby
that's where he sits so everyone knows
what two girls one cup is but the one
man one just answered them for people oh
for god's sake just for people right so
if you don't know two girls one cup it's
just like a weird
is that a fetish
thing it's just crazy it's just like a
lot of poo play
fecal yeah it's just fecal matter
everywhere everywhere and
i don't know what drugs they took
but their [ __ ] comes out like soft scoop
ice cream
and they're just eating it
constantly
there's just two girls
with a cup
and they're just eating crap
literally for three four minutes from
every angle you can imagine and it's the
most grotesque thing i've ever seen in
my life
one man one jar
is a dude who likes to sit on stuff
um and he gets a glass jar like a mason
jar or whatever
and he's got
hemorrhoids on his arm
do you remember no i actually don't
battle's covered in warts bro
i don't remember it's all over the gup
it's grim and he he sits on
this glass jar to see if he can fit it
up there and the pressure
cracks the glass jar is while it's
inside him and he has to pull the shards
out
and it it it just dried everywhere
there's just like blood everywhere it's
the craziest scariest most horrible
thing i've ever seen
[Laughter]
do you know what that's reminding me of
have you ever heard of pain olympics
did i ever show you about that no i saw
this i think i saw this in college
so pain olympics is similar to like two
girls one cup and one my one horse blah
blah
it's again another fetish where
people inflict pain on other people for
pleasure
so i remember seeing
uh
one yes stamping on a guy's balls
damping on it and every time like
it was every time she did it i was like
oh my god i couldn't believe it i'm sure
that's torture i am sure there was like
like knives involved no people were cut
and [ __ ]
i can't remember properly i promise you
i promise you hand on heart no man then
we're topping stuff off i promise you
i promise you is this on the dark web
bro where did you find this this was
back a day this is when [ __ ] was loose
you could get you could get anything and
you'll find what you wanted yeah so i
don't know if you can find it now but
this was probably a decade and a half
ago it was a it was a long time ago it
was bro payne olympics
their men were [ __ ] cutting [ __ ] they
were cutting [ __ ] for pleasure no no no
no no no no no no no it was west it was
west i'm good bro but yeah back to the
would you rather this is definitely a
pick your poison but you said would i
rather be involved in two girls and
welcome so you have to be a participant
in two girls one cup so you're one of
the girls
or you have to be the guy in one man one
jar i generally don't think i can shove
anything on my back for it to crack and
then yank it out
i'm dying james
because i don't think
yes the two girls one cup is grotesque
but i don't actually think i'll die from
it you know i don't think i would i'll
confirm it i i i i once i
leave i confirm it's almost like a
stomach the smell yeah i would like to
believe i can [ __ ] vomit so many
times but i could get through it but
trust me i am not sticking a jar on my
bag i promise you that bro cracked
the shattered the shards he's pulling
out shattered his body
oh it took my breath away i remember
because as it cracks
the blade closes over it yeah and he has
to just just peel out the oh it's so
grim and the blood's like oh
it's like a puddle of blood on the floor
and you're like get to the hospital now
but you can't even you need to get them
out
he can't walk
nah nah
that i don't think anyone's ever been as
scared as he was in that minute
you probably enjoyed it bro no no
he stuck the jar up he's back himself i
know but he didn't see that eventuality
he didn't think that was even a thing he
must have he must have
found i remember him
like that and i was thinking oh and he
pulled out and just
just blow like everywhere and then the
next shot on the next chart no
no how do you explain that to the doctor
i don't think you need to
i don't think you need to explain
anything fair enough they've seen it all
bro true they have they've seen it all
that's wild
i if i was a doctor what's wrong with
you i would love to know if anyone that
listens to us is a doctor or a nurse or
someone that works on hospital please
let us know what the wildest thing
you've ever seen oh please please let us
know what's the wildest thing you've
ever seen anymore please do that please
do that's intriguing to me that's actual
one yeah yeah please do that because i
watched obviously i've seen like grey's
anatomy i've seen like hospital shows
and they always show random [ __ ] like
you've got something stuck up his ass
blah blah obviously that's all fake but
it's stemmed from a bit of truth so
please let us know what you guys want
i'd love that oh my god that's wild oh
yeah now man people need help they do
they really do that's yeah so that's a
grotesque would you rather we're both
going two guys won't go 100 percent yeah
i couldn't stick anything on my belly
like that one more
that big no it's like probably bigger
than this it's bigger than that it's
bigger wise it was bigger than that nah
brother
nah bravo
nah brother
um
one man one horse is a ridic you
definitely showed me one more hole yeah
because i remember you telling me that
when he gets it in he goes
what the horse the guy
[Music]
i don't remember again i remember you
telling me and i was crying
wait
i think i it rings a bell because i
think i said afterwards he died he did
die yeah yeah
yeah
tommy died i remember it was you it was
you definitely you showed me that video
he's his hands against the floor
they pick the horse up shove the horse
in him
you can't enjoy that
you can't enjoy it that's that you can't
enjoy that i don't care
what would make you want to do such a
thing man bro i don't know a horse is
tall is like my leg
bro i don't know apparently there's a
video i haven't seen it there was a
video where um
sounds like this pain olympics thing to
be fair is
with one there's
[Music]
there's two breaders two brothers laying
flat in the stomach a leg spread
and another brother
um
behind them yeah and he fists them a man
just going
and as he's pulling it out
the the the ting comes out like his
inside the inside of the anus comes out
that pink thing yeah so he's just like
and they're just there just just
squealing oh korean i don't know what
people go for i don't know why people go
through this man nah
man man two man yeah
nah man anus just murked
no i don't know how people can can put
up with that that's not pleasure
you
i wonder
what
the tipping point was because obviously
these men back in the day when they go
we're having regular sex yeah the
gateway drug you want to know what like
what what tipped them to be like big man
this isn't doing it for me get your arm
up there
get your arm up there now that's what i
want nah
nah imagine being
imagine being the guy the other guy who
said oh get my arm up there you just
look at him like what
my arm my arm
get your whole arm up there you sure not
a big man i would leave the hole
i would leave the building you're lost
you're a lost soul you need help no
brother there are certain things in life
that
shouldn't be a turn-on oh yeah trust me
there shouldn't be a turn right now
that's west let us know in the comments
what you guys would choose because yeah
both as disgusting as each other but bro
that's a good with your other that is
because it made me think but i already
knew which one was going to choose but
they're both disgusting bro can you
imagine having like
how [ __ ] must it be to have like a
really weird fetish or something like
that
and you're just like for god's sake
that's just what does it for me no one
else would understand i remember
watching i was watching i started
watching master of none again okay i
watched the whole thing again the other
day
great show so um
i was watching it and there's an episode
where they catch um
they catch
a guy bashing on the on the subway okay
i don't remember this by the way in
public and they catch him okay they do
like a uh like a uh what they call it
like a public arrest or whatever okay um
or citizens rest that's the one public
arrest citizens arrested a citizen's
arrest and they're gassed
and they ask him like why are you
bashing on the flipping train like
what's when he's getting arrested there
why are you bashing the train like
what's wrong with you he's like i don't
know man it just like it just turns
melon in it so i have to do it and it's
like it's a compulsion
and then he goes um
like yeah but that's gross man like
white and he's like yeah it's gross to
you because it's not
your face but if it was
if that's what then if that's what
what you were into then i bet you'd have
some real internal conflict and then
aziz is like [ __ ]
yeah he's like i feel bad for you now
damn so it's not my fault
it's not my father real internal
conflicts like [ __ ] when he said that i
was like what a sentence [ __ ] what ways
are phrases i bet if it was you you'd
have some real internal conflicts [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that must be horrible it's like
that's your drive that's what get that's
what gets you going and you're like i
don't want it to be what gets me going
it just is
damn it just is damn
that's a tipping point bro bro that
reminds me of great movie
the michael fassbender movie shame
before we go i need to piss great
first scheduled for liftoff
the new lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
this spaceship is here to guide you on a
journey to trim your body
balls butt
and even uranus
[Laughter]
and even uranus
this fourth generation trimmer also
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 has a 7 000 rpm motor big
man you can feel the difference for real
for all
um
and uh yeah so
sorry 7000 rpm motor new multi-function
on and off switch and the gauge travel
lock and there's even
waterproof guys
so we've been through this before you
already know the dealios
it's waterproof it's fast with the
diseases
you can trim everywhere and you can get
that
that's that sound you need to hear bro
that's that sound you need to hear
that's the journey we're on
that's the journey we're on jump in
so if you want to get involved guys you
know what to do manscape.com
um discount code is sng 20 off
uh free shipping worldwide sng sierra
november golf
manscape.com 20 off free chipping jump
in
performance package 4.0 lawnmower 4.0
let's go back to the episode
come on
shame shame
great movie you spoke about it i don't
think you've spoken about on here before
but we've definitely spoken about it
before bro great movie i need to watch
that again to be fair there's one scene
in there in terms of internal conflict
there's one scene in there
where he
was doing a thing with the girl from
work
the black thing from what i don't think
because i've seen it once and it was a
long time ago i don't remember the whole
movie but i remember the premise of the
movie gang right cool so for people
shane michael fassbender is a movie
about dude who has like terrible sex
edition right
and um there's one scene where
he
he also
sex is not like a thing for him it's
like a not a um how to explain it
there's no emotion attached to it for
him it's all a physical act it's just a
release for him
so um
he struggles to relay i don't know what
happened in his life because i think his
sister suffers from the same thing
um or they've him and his sister are
both pretty [ __ ] up but basically he's
got this addiction
um and he struggles to
connect intimacy with sex he can't do it
so there's one bit where he's um
he's he fancies like he's he he starts
basically seeing some woman from work
um
they like each other etc and one day in
the middle of the day they're like he's
like let's go let's go they get a hotel
room in the middle of the day
banging view everything start getting
down to it
just about to get into it because it's
so emotional and stuff like that like
he can't get up
he's down for her he can't get up
so
she leaves and he's like [ __ ]
cause a prostitute
bangs the prostitute in there
[ __ ] and you're like
you know he's just like oh internal
conflict or what literal shame
literal shame he's just like what is
wrong and you just know after that he's
like what is wrong with me
the one thing i liked about that movie
is because i remember the beginning of
it
i think for the like the first five ten
minutes he didn't he didn't say a word
but he understood what the movie was
about yeah because the first scene is
him on like the train and he's just
stare he's staring at one thing
she feels awkward but then she gets into
it and then she's wearing like some
skirt with like some long socks and then
she just like creeps up just to get a
little bit of skin man staring at her
bruv
it's intense it's such an intense scene
intense and then he goes to move to her
she panics and she just jumps the thing
oh man michael fassbend is a good actor
in that movie great actor in that movie
and then it comes full circle at the end
where he's just dealing with his own
issues he's dealing with his own issues
and he's annoyed he's just like oh why
is this like my life and he's on the
train again like vex
and then he sees the same yeah again and
she stares at him
and you can tell he's just like i can't
deal with this today and he looks away
and then a second later he's just like
looks back at her and you just know he's
like i can't help myself i can't i'm an
addicted i can't help myself
and you're like oh what a movie
one movie great movie
um
but yeah man uh i i would hate to have
that i would hate to have like there's a
certain thing that just like
that gets it going for me and it's super
controversial yeah really polarizing
there's nothing i can do about it
nothing you can do about it it's it's uh
and it's like unless i want to go
without knight and ever again then i
have to do it i have to do it i have to
do it i've got no choice
i've got no choice
and if that's me fapping on the public
train then guess what i'm vaping on the
public trade i've happened on public
training i'm answering the internal
conflict that was a great phrasing
probably where he was
um right uh am i the [ __ ] let's go
for a g hmm this is actually this
coincidentally wasn't intended but it
does actually bode well into
this conversation
oh right i'm not gonna lie it's kind of
a long one okay but
we'll see how it goes
right so title of this one am i the
[ __ ] for locking off a ting because
she wouldn't give me any coochie
here we go so
i said so this is a kind of long one but
i want to get your opinion
right
guys help us help you okay just for
future reference yeah
when it's a long one when you're like oh
this is kind of long
how do i explain it i know sometimes
this fridge man
sometimes we ask for extra details and
actually stuff like that but if you if
there's bits in there that are just
irrelevant information
get rid of it
get rid of it get rid of it this is a
spectator sport get rid of it
get rid of it
i don't need to know that like
you had this weird text exchange that's
completely unrelated to
what the point is yeah yeah get rid of
it
write everything down then edit it yeah
edit it yeah yeah yeah edit it out and
send us the crux of the story so we can
get like formulate just just give us
enough context so that we can formulate
uh like a well-informed uh opinion and
leave it there i don't need six pages of
information i know because when you put
too much it doesn't really paint that
much of a picture yeah we get lost in
the fam sometimes when you read them out
to me
i'm with you for a good 65 seconds
after that i'm just like what's the yawn
about
what's your name
i know
i don't blame you but fam i'm just like
what are they on about
right
so
right
so what i'm going to do just for future
reference i'm going to read this out
then i'm going to tell you what we could
edit out
okay yeah yeah right yeah yeah so i'm on
the also for looking at think she
wouldn't give me any coochie so man say
this is kind of long but i want to get
your opinion okay so i met this girl a
while ago and we're here off pretty well
we started chatting for hours at a time
over the first few days
i said this girl was thick and had
curves in all the right places
i mean
and i said and i wanted to get me some
again like edit that out we don't need
to know that
sometimes i understand why they do it
obviously yes i understand because
they're trying to paint a picture like
this girl's banging i know but i just
decided yeah they're excited they're
like yeah this guy's just playing i get
that i get that
to be fair yeah you're right you're
right you're right oh you can leave that
if you want
um i just for me i just assumed that the
girl's banging in their eyes exactly in
their eyes if we were talking about this
then i'm assuming she's like anyway i
don't need to know that she's she's
banging
like she's thinking this is a skank yeah
right so we both weren't looking for
anything serious at the time and it was
all chill we were talking for about a
month and i noticed whenever i tried to
move us into sexual conversation or try
to
do a thing when we when we were in
person
she would shut it down and i would just
let it go
the man put in brackets no means no and
i respect that
after all i'm not trying to catch a case
right
sir
you've really really got a good high
ground moral higher ground when you say
no means no and i respect that
you really diminish that when you say
after all i ain't trying to catch a case
it's double-edged
it's double-edged thumb it's like saying
murder is wrong and i i don't want to
murder people
but if push comes to the shoulder switch
but really
i just don't want to go to jail yeah
that's that's what you say is what
you're saying
i really do want to murder people but i
just don't want to get caught
that's what you're saying
and i respect that but really i just
don't want to go pen for rape
that's what you just said
right anyway
um i brought it up because i was going
on
i brought it up because it was going on
for a while and i asked waguan and she
said she was a virgin and she didn't
want to do it with any random brother
bear in mind we're both in our late 20s
lord i told her i understand but i
personally think that's a lot
i understand but i personally think that
physical relationship isn't is an
important is as he's
that's not my fault
i can read this is not my fault i can
read just to clarify this physical
relationship is as important as what he
meant to write as an emotional one
agreed and if she doesn't agree then
it's best to call it quits and go our
separate ways but she wanted to see
where things went with us so we kept
seeing each other
we kept on seeing each other and i
developed feelings for this girl and the
whole no sex thing started to play on my
mind
after about five months five months i
suggested that we go away for a beach
weekend because we couldn't do anything
fun because of covert and everything
being closed and i needed to distract
myself from trying knitting
with her when we were alone
say that again yeah that doesn't make
sense
so
he said arts basically after five months
he suggested that they go away because
they couldn't do anything else fun
because of kovid and he needed a
distraction
for trying from trying to ting with her
when they're aligned
so i'm thinking what he's trying to say
is they were bored locked in all the
time because of covid and when they're
born and locked in he just wants to
smash so he's trying to think of other
things that they can go and do to get
his head off of it
that being said going away for the
weekend is that's all you're going to
want to smash
again double edge
yeah that doesn't make any sense
next sentence she said no because all i
wanted was sex there you go there you go
bro i explained to her again that sex is
something that is important for me and i
think you need to be essentially
compatible with your partner because
there is no point spending a year with
someone uh without sex just to find out
that you're not on the same wave in bed
she said i was just interested in her
body and i told her honestly your body
was the first reason that i liked you
and she got even madder at that
obviously
obviously my god you put what duh
there's ways you say stuff brother
this that wasn't the right time order
please bro literally i said obviously
obviously that's the last reason that's
the first reason i liked you my g
i tried a couple more times over the
next couple of months after that to link
her um away and go on a vacation
together but she insisted that i was
just trying to clap cheeks
so i told her if that's what she thinks
then she really doesn't know me and we
need to end things she called me a
fuckboy and all manner of other things
because of this she started telling her
friends who knew some of my friends that
wasn't [ __ ] and i only used women
for sex and my female friends had a
conversation with me and this got me mad
so i called her and cluster out on the
phone
i know this was immature but she was
destroying my name for no good reason in
my opinion so i might be [ __ ] for
ending things because this chick didn't
want to sleep with me
um i think just off the backyard also
for pursuing this when you said
it's five months down the line you try
to take her away and blah blah blah like
if you know we both agree that
sexual
um the sexual and the physical and the
what's the word though he said emotional
attraction and sexual attraction yes sir
sexual attraction and emotional
attraction yes are both important in
relationship if you knew from the jump
if she said to you from the drum big man
i'm a virgin she said late 20s she's
obviously not just sleeping around she's
been a virgin you know you clearly want
to [ __ ] her because like you said she's
a tick ting that's the first thing you
saw and blah blah blah you got attracted
that understandable but if she's
if she's a virgin at late 20s
she's not just going to bust it over for
you bro so you should have just learned
from that from the jump and be like
listen i understand
it's not going to work out and just kept
it moving bro you should have just kept
it moving i understand the attraction
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong if
she's tick ticking all the right places
like you said i understand especially if
you see her on a regular basis you're
going to want to smash her on a regular
basis but you should have just done the
right thing i just noticed you should
have locked this whole vacation thing on
a weekend blah blah blah stupid
waste the money yeah and you said at the
beginning you you're both not looking
for anything serious so for in her
perspective
if she knows you're not looking for
anything serious but you're you're
trying to book vacations you're trying
to do this you're trying to do that like
she's gonna think just just trying to
just trying to say he's just looking for
ways to swindle me because he already
done told me he doesn't want a
girlfriend so he doesn't want a
girlfriend why is he trying to spend all
this time with me
but then again what does it mean when a
woman says i'm just looking for
something casual if they're not
willing to have sex because i don't know
what that again i don't understand i
don't know what casual yeah i don't know
yeah i'm not putting all the earnest on
him because she's cracked i don't know
what casual she's cracked what are we
doing just going for food and talking
yeah yeah are you looking for a friend
that's what you're looking yeah if
you're looking for a friend there's
batman out there yeah you guys bag a man
out there that wants to be your friend
that will happily be your friend you
know yeah yeah i don't know what casual
means if you're not having sex yeah i
generally don't that's the definition of
casual that's what we're talking about
that's literally what we're talking
about i just want to clap and dip
and it's mutual that's what casual is
right so yeah
yeah man that's again double edged yeah
she's got some internal conflicts
herself
because boy i don't know what she's on
about but yeah as soon as you you need
to address red flags young man you need
to address young red flags because
late 20s virgin
immediate red flag
and it's
and i'm not saying that's a bad thing
it's not a bad thing because it just is
what is she decided to choose to be a
virgin and that's her choice that's fine
but
if you know who you are as a person that
you want to smash
it's a red flag for you and that's just
a fact it's not a brain it's a
no-brainer i would
bro if i'm in that situation i'm trying
to think like yeah yeah all good or good
or good yeah yeah what are you looking
for something casual to be fair just
looking to have a bit of fun yeah yeah
me too yeah yeah
okay we meet up yeah yeah good day yeah
yeah i'm trying to smash and she's like
nah nah nah i'm not really about that
and i'm like oh i swear okay what's
going on she's like oh to be fair i'm a
virgin man but you're 29.
it's like yeah yeah no no but all this
stuff
cool
i'm out i'm
respectfully i'm out because i don't
know what casual means to me
this isn't going to work casual means to
you this isn't going to work i'm telling
you off the bat it's not going to work
i'm just going to have a hard dick all
the time yeah big man it's not going to
work and because like i said to you i'm
looking for something casual babes i
don't want to be the guy to guide you
through this sexual journey nah i'm not
the one there's too much responsibility
for me for one she's going to remember
it for the rest of us there's too much
responding i'm i'm a passer through guy
i'm mr right now i'm not mr right the
right there we go there we go
i missed him right now and right now
you're not looking for me
so respectfully i'm i'm i'm out yeah you
ain't got your numbers together uh i'm
out uh that
and he said he's late 20s as well right
yeah they're both like 20s man you could
have had an open and honest conversation
oh bro you could have just been opening
blood babes i understand that i respect
that i think that's actually very cool
um
but
like i said to you i'm looking i'm
looking for a casual relationship babes
and the sex is going to be a big part of
that for me
and then she turns around she says bang
me then
then and even then i'm like yeah
like i said too much really nah
[Music]
i know you know
your hymen is sacred
hold that next rank and can bust through
that like i'm i'm gonna find i'm just
i'm just looking for
for kelly's on road didn't it
i'm not here for that that's too much
response yeah and then yeah bro and but
then again yeah so obviously
you're both [ __ ] but you are mainly
you ignored red flags to start with you
continue to pursue the thing and then
i can see why she thought you were just
out to clap because big man like
she done said she's not trying to bang
and you've done said that you're not
looking for a girlfriend but you're
orchestrating stuff about five
months bro
as soon as you said that i was like what
are we even discussing yeah yeah five
months you you've been known she's a
virgin since month one yeah you're five
months in and you're still trying to
orchestrate stuff come on bro have some
selfies yeah bro unless you're going to
make it your misses like i don't know
what you're doing
it's not casual anymore it's really not
casual you're wasting time you're
wasting each other's time
bro
big man yeah what a waste of time yeah
mom sorry bro what waste of time
that should have been an open show like
this is what i've said before i feel
like people don't re re-read what they
write before they send it big one
literally sometimes i think if you like
this is why i should probably keep a
diary because when people have turmoil
yeah
just write it down and then just read it
from an outsider's perspective and think
i understand now i understand where i
went wrong yeah yeah yeah this is so
obvious obvious she told me from the
jump big man i'm a virgin i'm not trying
to bang and i was like that's fine
i mean it's important for me but i'm
willing to respect that
half a year later
am i trying to organize let's go on
vacation big man stop trying to fight me
i'm not gonna [ __ ] you i told you it's
important to me that's it he got
immediate defensive in it i told you
what's important to me she said see you
are just trying to [ __ ] me
babe's just going a beach vacation oh
you're trying to fight me again big man
we can go on the vacay but stop trying
to bang me please
but they're [ __ ] it's important to me
this oh it's backwards bro
backwards double edge three times in
this whole yeah yeah yeah you you
allowed her to have that opinion of you
yeah you allowed her to do that big man
you're both ourselves but i think you're
an [ __ ] for the wrong reason yeah
yeah yeah yeah 100 100 percent 100
percent yeah you should have told us
babes i'm i'm i'm i'm at it
i'm trying to slang
i'm trying to swing pipe left and right
and you're gonna have to respect that as
well so i'm out there we go i'm gonna
respect you a lot more for being honest
100 percent for honestly 100 and then
when she was ready
see what if she you literally she want a
holly because she knows you're about it
he knows you're about your experience
your experience you're a wizard with the
thing oh bro you fumbled the whole bag
especially
i can picture it i can picture you did
fumble it bro honesty is the best policy
my g you just say it you just say it
like babes i'm just not here for this
and they accept it yeah they have no
choice in the black you know what that's
fair
that's fair and then later on when when
she is ready she said she's she's had a
few dead pipes and she's like all right
cool i'm ready to be in in the streets
that's you're next what's next you
didn't even try now you've wasted five
months and you'll never be there you're
never gonna [ __ ] her you're never gonna
[ __ ] enough because she's gonna remember
these five months for the rest of my
life yeah yeah yeah you're never gonna
get to you bro so yeah completely not a
waste of time sorry bro it is what it is
but um on that note i think it's a wrap
yeah mum and uh guys love love love
[Music]